[Musica]
mentre Chi io era Virgilio congiunto
super lo Monte che l'anime cura e
discendendo del mondo defunto dettenni
fuori di mia vita futura parole gravi
avvenia che io mi senta ben tetragono a
rischi di ventura perché la voglia mia
Sarria contenta di intender qual fortuna
mi sapressa che Saetta precisa vien più
lenta
sono parole di Dante Pellegrino nel
cielo di Marte nella terza cantica del
libro più incredibile mai scritto da
essere umano Il Paradiso Dante è
arrivato nel cielo di Marte nel cielo
degli spiriti Combattenti per la fede
incontra il trizavolo il trisnonno
Caccia Guida a cui domanda responso a
cui chiede conferma di ciò che lo
accompagna fin dall'inizio del suo
viaggio ultra mondano aveva avuto
accenni di ciò che gli sarebbe accaduto
nel futuro a partire dal fondo
dell'inferno arrivato lassù di fronte al
trizavolo chiede
di dar conferma di ciò che lo aspetta
perché dice chi sa cosa lo aspetta può
prevedere che arrivi la saetta e Saetta
prevista sembra venir più lenta si può
schivare per tentare di salvarsi avvegna
dice Dante che io sia tetragono cubico
resistente ai colpi di ventura cosa
m'aspetta nonno predici il mio passato
Sì avete capito bene i trisavolo
cacciaguida fa una previsione una
profezia sul passato
siamo Nell'anno del viaggio di Dante
Alighieri nel 1300 l'anno del primo
Giubileo della storia ha voluto da papa
Bonifacio Ottavo causa prima dell'esilio
del poeta siamo nel 1300 i protagonisti
di questo viaggio è Dante Pellegrino ma
l'autore di questo viaggio Dante poeta
scrive la Divina Commedia a partire
dal 1302 forse comunque dopo quell'anno
fatidico del viaggio ultra mondano
questo canto in particolare il
diciassettesimo di Paradiso Dante lo sta
scrivendo probabilmente a Verona negli
ultimi mesi del suo soggiorno Veronese
Siamo intorno al 130018 19 forse 1.320
Perciò il poeta Dante Alighieri l'autore
della Divina Commedia sa bene cosa
gli è toccato dopo il 1300 ha già
vissuto ciò che il protagonista del
viaggio Dante Pellegrino sta chiedendo
al nonnetto cacciaguida nel cielo di
Marte Ecco che Dante poeta fa predire al
suo trisavolo il passato che ha già
vissuto
il passato che bene o male tutti noi
perfino noi sette secoli dopo conosciamo
di come quest'uomo nato a Firenze nel
1265 arrivato al massimo della carica
politica Fiorentina a priori di Firenze
per essersi opposto ai voleri di qualche
famiglia e soprattutto ai voleri di
Bonifacio VIII Papa a Roma sia stato
condannato per baratteria e sia stato
costretto a lasciare la sua Firenze ed
essere esiliato e non tornar mai più
nella sua città Ecco che Dante si fa
predire dal trisavolo
quello che ha già vissuto quello che I
lettori della commedia conoscono già
Ecco un geniale meccanismo
di mettere in connessione il presente
con il passato un Ritorno al futuro per
citare un film che abbiamo visto molti
molti anni dopo ecco perché la Divina
Commedia diventa subito immediatamente
Letta capita apprezzata discussa dai
contemporanei Perché Dante Alighieri
racconta in questo libro ciò che i
contemporanei oltre che lui stesso ha
già vissuto
di più se prendiamo il presente di Dante
che scrive la Divina Commedia pensiamo
il passato di Dante Pellegrino troveremo
la connessione con il futuro Sì perché
sempre nel canto XVII Dante chiede
ancora al trisavolo cacciaguida
giù per lo mondo senza fine amaro e per
lo Monte del cui belcacume gli occhi
della mia donna mi levarono e poscia per
l'ocel di lume in lume o io appreso ciò
che si io ridico a molti fiasapor di
Forte agrume e Sio al verso un timido
amico temo di perder viver tra coloro
che questo tempo chiameranno antico
coloro che questo tempo chiameranno
antico siamo noi
sei tu sei tu tu tu
ciascuno e ciascuno di noi
tra coloro che questo tempo chiameranno
antico Dante sapeva che saremmo stati
qui al The X di bulka in questa giornata
anzi Lui ci ha convocato qui Ciao
previsto qui per 30 volte all'interno
della Divina Commedia Dante interrompe
la narrazione e si rivolge a ciascuno di
noi pensa lettore pensa lettrice non ci
chiama lettori elettrici
in gruppo no si rivolge personalmente a
ciascuno di noi sa che la lettura del
suo libro
interverrà nella vita di ciascuno dei
lettori che lo leggeranno per il tempo
che verrà letto e cambierà la vita
entrerà succederà qualcosa dentro la
persona che sta leggendo quel libro
altrisavolo cacciaguida cosa chiede
Dante oltre aver chiesto di profetizzare
il passato che già conosceva chiede
permesso e guardate che lo sta chiedendo
a se stesso perché stiamo parlando del
poeta del libro che chiede a se stesso
di scrivere cosa
nonno dice scendendo l'inferno salendo
il Purgatorio Io ne ho sentite e ne ho
viste Ho incontrato papi ho incontrato
principi ho incontrato Vescovi
imperatori ho sentito di ladrocini di
sotterfugi ho sentito di ingiustizie
Quante ingiustizie ho visto adulatori
bartieri Ladri seminatori di discordie e
indovini ho visto stupratori omicidio ho
sentito parlare della politica
dell'economia della religione della
chiesa quante ne ho viste o sentite ora
nonno
cosa faccio lo scrivo ma perché se lo
scrivo temo per la mia vita
Ma se non lo scrivo
se non racconto la verità
tra sette secoli a Bolca
saranno ancora lì che leggono il mio
libro
se io
alverson timido amico non sono amico
della verità
temo di perder vita tra coloro che
questo tempo chiameranno antico in poche
parole se non la racconto giusta il mio
libro non lo leggeranno fra 7 secoli
il mio libro finirà come tanti libri
della storia dell'umanità su cui si è
posata la polvere e nessuno più ha
soffiato per scaraventarla via e
leggerlo
Dante sta chiedendo il permesso a se
stesso di raccontare la verità una
verità che ancora ci interroga perché
ancora oggi siamo qui a leggerlo quel
libro e trisavolo cacciaguida
prende la parola ed è Dante che prende
la parola e dice coscienza fusca o della
propria o della altrui vergogna pur
sentirà la tua parola brusca sì Chi ha
la coscienza sporca chi sa di avere la
coscienza sporca si vergognerà e sentirà
che la tua parola e brusca Sì fa male la
parola che dice la verità se c'è la
coscienza sporca non di me dice Dante a
se stesso e lo sta dicendo a ciascuno di
noi rimossa ogni menzogna tutta tua
visione fa manifesta
e lascia pur grattar Dov'è la rogna
Non preoccuparti
lascia pure che chi ha la coscienza
sporca gratti la sua rogna di tutta la
verità e quanto più la dirai alta quanto
percuoterà le altre cime perché se la
tua parola nel primo gusto
creerà disagio e sembrerà indigesta
quando sarà digerita
sarà nutrimento per l'anima
questo tuo grido che più scuoterà le
cime in alto cime di potenti cime di
famosi cime di persone che sono
protagoniste dell'evoluzione storica più
sarà letta e ascoltata da coloro che
questo tempo chiameranno antico
il presente di Dante il passato del suo
esilio aver previsto che dopo mille anni
questa sua opera sarà letta e conosciuta
pur in questo tempo il nostro tempo che
Dante Alighieri probabilmente
chiamerebbe un'epoca grossa Anzi forse
grossissima e grossa significa Greve
bassa spenta senza ideali senza
aspirazioni Senza novità e L'undicesimo
canto di Purgatorio Dante parlando della
fama e mettendosi nella cornice tra i
Superbi racconta di come sembrava L'arte
di Cimabue primaggiare ad essere
destinata a essere ricordata per sempre
ed ora arrivato Giotto a togliere il
primato dell'arte così la poesia di
Guido Guinizzelli ha ceduto alla poesia
di Guido Cavalcanti e forse è nato
Qualcuno dice Dante e dice forse sono
nato io che scalzerò dal nido l'uno e
l'altro
perché non è mondar rumore il montar
rumore è successo sono le
visualizzazioni su YouTube del Ted X non
è mondar rumore altro che un fiato di
vento
corvien Quinci orvien Quindi e mutanome
come muta lato
tira il vento e si cambia nome si cambia
partito si cambia idea
si cambia fedeltà e fiducia si tradisce
Sì se io non dico la verità racconta
Dante
quest'epoca sarà dimenticata e fra mille
anni nel 2022 in un'epoca grossa
grossissima e noi non possiamo saperlo
ma Cosa resterà di questa epoca lo
sapremo fra mille anni resterà qualche
libro di questo nostro tempo
qualche manufatto architettonico qualche
quadro qualche scultura resterà C'è
qualcuno oggi che scriverà una Divina
Commedia
questa nostra epoca grossa non legge più
i classici su questa montagna Dante
Alighieri veniva letto studiato e
imparato a memoria nelle stalle di Bolca
di Vestenanova di Selva di Progno di
Sant'Ambrogio di San Bortolo c'era
sempre qualcuno che la sera attaccava
durante i Filò la riunione serale nelle
stalle e diceva a memoria un passo di
Dante chissà che abbia citato anche il
diciassettesimo di paradiso Noi abbiamo
dimenticato Perfino i classici I
classici Che come diceva Vittorio
Sermonti ci leggono molto più di quanto
Noi leggiamo loro
Bisognerebbe ripartire da qui dalla
saggezza di contadini che la sera nella
stalla leggevano la commedia di Dante
sapevano che Dante gli aveva convocati
loro noi tu tu tu tu tu che il suo tempo
che amiamo antico
[Applauso]
[Musica]